Unity 2020 is the plan to be awarded
enough electoral college votes in order
to put the decision to the house if this
isn't the plan please elaborate on your
specific path forward which states show
the most promise for a dark horse
what about Kasich yang my crowd seeing
it cry such yes it's um so let me
address these in sequence one we thought
our biggest obstacle was ballot access
it turns out there are at least four
paths to ballot access that would not
require this to be thrown to the house
so all I will say is it does not make
sense for us to discuss the details of
that plan yet that actually we will
remove some of the potential by
discussing them ahead of time in other
words people who are not interested in
seeing us restore power to the people
will take up arms against it and the
more they know the worse off we are but
what I would say is stay tuned you will
very quickly discover what those routes
are and we can talk about which ones are
most likely and it may be that it's a
hybrid strategy but there are ways to do
it we were actually pleasantly surprised
when we looked into this matter and as
far as Kasich yang which states show the
most promise and what about cases yeah
well it's not a which states we're
talking about all 50 states and this is
plausible we you know we tried to talk
ourselves out of this because if it
wasn't really possible we didn't want to
put our necks out but we ended up
talking ourselves into the fact that
this is possible you know what you can
do to make it more possible sign up add
to our numbers it costs you nothing it
takes no time and if you do it then
people who are looking at us thinking
that's a really cool plan but it's never
gonna work those people will start to
come over and what you'll get is
positive feedback and positive feedback
as you know is the most powerful force
in the universe so let's get there all
right the last question is Kasich yang
you know we have a list of people who if
either yang or McRaven are not available
for this or are unwilling and frankly I
don't think either of them would be
unwilling but there is a question about
can they and if they can't then we have
a list of people who could slot in
either place you will notice in our
document
the articles of unity we do not mention
any candidates because the important
thing is the plan and there are great
many people who could inhabit either of
these spots and would do an excellent
job because of course the key to any
administration is going to be who it's
listening to right who is it going to
bring in to decide what to do about
environmental questions about economic
questions about the danger posed to us
by our enemies nobody's a superhero
people don't have encyclopedic knowledge
of how the world works on every topic so
it's going to be a question of who they
bring in and how they make decisions and
if they're patriotic and they're
courageous and they're capable and they
bring in the right people why are we on
a better path
[Music]